pas la parole est à monsieur olivier
marleix
ma question s'adresse au nouveau
ministre de l'intérieur et j'ai aussi
mon collègue guy teissier à l'heure où
l'europe reste confronté à un niveau de
menace
inédit la mission la gendarmerie
nationale est gravement désorganisé par
l'application de la directive européenne
sur le temps de travail cette directive
de 2003 qui définit des période minimale
de repos excluait pourtant expressément
les forces armées ou la police mais
c'était sans compter sur l'intervention
de la cour de justice de l'union
européenne qui a décidé que ces
dispositions devaient leur être
appliquée la gendarmerie nationale a
donc commencé depuis le 1er septembre à
l'initiative de votre prédécesseur a
transposé en partie cette directive avec
application d'un repos journalier de 11h
par période de 24 heures
cette décision pose trois problèmes
d'abord c'est une remise en cause de
l'identité de la gendarmerie qui obéit à
un principe militaire de disponibilité
c'est ensuite un véritable casse tête
administratif pour les commandants de
brigade qui n'arrivent plus à boucler
leurs plannings et au total ce qui a
évidemment encore plus grave il aurait
une baisse considérable de la capacité
opérationnelle de la gendarmerie
auditionné par le cas me suis par la
commission de la défense de 18 octobre
dernier le général du rpt est directeur
général de la bri a indiqué que cette
nouvelle organisation du temps de
travail représentait l'équivalent de
5000 postes en moins dans la gendarmerie
et le pire est à venir monsieur le
ministre puisque si la directive et à
appliquer totalement lorsqu'un gendarme
assurera une garde à vue de 96 heures ce
quelqu'un matière de terrorisme la
gendarmerie devra le passé pour 15 jours
en repos obligatoire très concrètement
donc monsieur le ministre dans le
contexte actuel de mobilisation des
forces de l'ordre face à la menace
terroriste
comptez-vous prendre une initiative au
niveau européen pour que l'on sorte de
cette jurisprudence totalement insensé
et qu'on leur vienne à la lettre du
texte de la directive
la parole est à monsieur le ministre de
l'intérieur
bruno le roux monsieur le président
monsieur olivier marc l'ex je vous
remercie d'abord pour cette question qui
me permet de m'exprimer de dire avant
tout le plaisir que j'ai eu à travailler
durant ses quatre années avec le
christian jacob avec philippe vigier
avec roger gérard schwartzenberg avec ce
chassaigne sur les réunions de président
de groupe et le souci que nous avions de
pouvoir discuter autant qu'il le fallait
pour que les choses se passent bien je
continuerai à le faire et je veux avoir
le souci dans la période que vous avez
rappelé période de tension
particulièrement forte de pouvoir faire
en sorte que nos services de sécurité
puissent surmonter toutes les
difficultés et même les difficultés qui
sont créées par des directives
européennes sur lequel il ne faut pas
renoncer à essayer de les faire bouger
pour faire en sorte qu'elle ne
déstabilise pas le fonctionnement de nos
services je rencontrerai dans deux
heures après être sorti le directeur
général de la gendarmerie nationale pour
évoquer bien entendu cela avec lui le
travail a déjà été bien entendu
commencer par bernard cazeneuve
mon prédécesseur ce n'est pas simplement
un problème de discussion et
d'organisation c'est un problème que
nous devons aussi compensée par des
moyens des moyens qui correspondent à la
période
faut-il vous rappeler que le budget de
la gendarmerie
entre 2007 et 2012 avaient diminué de
15% alors qu'il augmente de plus de 12%
depuis 2012
c'est un élément important pour la
répartition sur le territoire des forces
de gendarmerie
j'étais à cergy hier soir avec ses
forces
je peux vous le dire que dans la façon
dont elles sont prises en considération
par le gouvernement par manuel valls et
bernard cazeneuve comme ministre de
l'intérieur puis comme premier ministre
elles ne se plaignent pas des moyens
dont elle dispose aujourd'hui
non simplement en crédits non simplement
en équipements mais aussi en personnel
et qui contraste bien avec ce que vous
avez fait auparavant la question n'est
pas simplement européenne
elle est aussi dans la politique que
vous aviez mairie jusqu'à